I want to pick up in Volume 13 and in December the 27th, 1921. The soul who lives in the divine will
places enforce the proceeds of creation. Louisa said that Jesus spoke to her saying,
"My daughter, every time the soul enters into my will, she comes to reflect herself in the mirror
of my divinity." And in reflecting herself, she receives the divine features.
And these features bind her to the divinity.
Now, every time the soul enters into my will, she comes to reflect herself in the mirror of
my divinity. There's two Corinthians 3, 18. You become like that which you worship. So here Jesus
is giving us the family recognition that's in the divine will family. So here we have the recognition.
So every time the soul enters into my will, she comes to reflect herself in the mirror of my divinity.
And in reflecting herself, she receives the divine features. And these features bind her
to the divinity. So this has been happening forever. It's just that we are entering into the
fullness of it. Now, if you go back to Exodus 34, verses 29 to 35, you have the story of Moses
going up the mountain, entering into the presence of God for 40 days and 40 nights, and coming back
with the glory of God all over him. And there was such a light shining from his face and from his
person that even Aaron, the high priest, couldn't tolerate it. And everybody was terrified of him.
In other words, he came back looking like God with this light and this glory and this presence
all over him. If you go to Hebrews chapter one verse three, there's a most wonderful statement
about Jesus. He is the radiant light of God's glory and the perfect copy of his nature.
So here Jesus is saying that every single time we fuse in the divine will and we enter in that
we begin to reflect each time that divinity. And therefore, it means it's like as if a painter
was painting a beautiful picture and each stroke adds to the picture adds to the picture adds to the
picture every brush stroke. And so that's the way it is with us as well. So that's Ephesians 210.
We are God's work of art created in Christ Jesus. So how do the three divine persons respond to this?
So when they see their own likeness, the word in my book is physiognomy, which is a bit big,
when they see their own likeness in the soul, the three divine persons recognize her as one
of their family. Now what you're talking about here are what he calls the true sons of God.
And the true sons of God are the ones referred to in Romans 819, the ones through whom everything
is going to be restored. So Romans 819. And I want to give you also one John three verses one to two
because you've entered so deeply into the relationship with God that the world of sin and all of that
is way, way behind. So the three divine persons recognize her as part of the DWF, divine will
family. They give her a place in their midst. Wow. Do you remember John 14 verses one and two?
I'm going to my father and there's a place for you. So as we come into the divine will every time
we fuse every time we do an act in the divine will, we are taking our place. They give her a place
in their midst and they admit her to their secrets. So we are told things that we can do in the divine
will, which the rest of the world wouldn't believe for any reason, whatever. And recognizing their own
will in the soul as the center of life. They admit her to that eternal point. That's the singularity
I've been talking about all the time. That single point that has no past and no future. Everything is
present. Everything is in action. Everything is happening there. And they enrich her with all
that eternity contains or how beautiful it is to see this little image of ours inundated
with all that eternity contains. Now I want you to notice the little word all.
One of the extraordinary things about God is his unbelievable, inexplicable humility.
Why should he want to share everything he has and everything he is with little absolute nobodies
like us? Now I know that the theological answer is that he is love. But you try and take it on
board. It's amazing. Oh how beautiful it is, Jesus said, to see this little image of ours inundated
with all that eternity contains being little. So there's our nothingness. She feels dissolved,
drowned, unable to contain it within herself naturally, because it's all far too immense.
And we're, as we go on in these writings, we're going to hear Louisa saying, I'm in this immense
sea. There's just no end to it. There's no way in and there's no way out.
Well, there was a way in through fusing all right, but there's no way out.
So I want to give you one Corinthians 1, 27, that he chooses the nobodies of this earth
to confound the strong. The strong ones of the earth wouldn't believe us at all that this was
possible. Being little, she feels dissolved and drowned and unable to contain it within herself,
would love with a capital L, therefore it is God. The carrying out of the life of our
volition within her pushes her to reflect herself in us while our eternal waves continue in her
like a machine that never ceases its motion. Oh, he said, how we enjoy ourselves. There's
your Proverbs 8, 31 again that God delights to be with the children of men. So here we have now
entered into the enormity of the gift of entering into the divine will and the actual presence of
the three divine persons and every single time we go in the Lord increases the painting of Jesus
on us so that we become more and more and more like him and that the three divine persons make
a place for us in heaven as Jesus promised and admit us to their secrets and recognizing their own
will in this soul as the center of life. They admitted to that eternal point and enriched with
all that eternity contains. You have to meditate on this. Oh, how beautiful it is to see this little
image of ours, this little miniature. That's fantastic. This little miniature of ours with all
that eternity contains. So if you've ever examined some of these great ancient paintings that
you'll find in museums, one of the things that fascinates me about them is that you have a main
picture and then you have pictures within that picture and each one of these tiny pictures
within the big picture is a complete picture. It's perfect. It's just a miniature inside of the
great picture and that's what we are, little miniatures inside of this incredible presence of God.
And so God who is love, that's one John four seven,
carries out the life of his divine will in the soul and pushes her to reflect herself in us.
While our eternal waves, Jesus said, continue in her like a machine that never ceases its motion,
it never stops. And as we go on in these writings, you'll hear Jesus saying, don't stop, don't stop,
keep going. This was the only purpose of the creation of man. Now we've heard this many times
through the exchange of our wills, he and us, the blessed Trinity, and we with him would form our
delight as well as to render man happy in everything. Okay, so the only purpose of creation was that
the human will would surrender to the divine will, let the divine will truly reign and both that
extraordinary exchange was going to bring about incredible happiness for both.
And eternal happiness for the man. As the union with our will was broken by man, our bitterness
began. The terrifying thing is that man gave God an experience he had never had before the creation
of man. And that experience was sorrow, bitterness, agony, and failure. These were experiences God had
never had before, but we gave them to him first class. And you'll hear Jesus lamenting in some of
the higher volumes, he said, how did he push it now? I was very unlucky in love, he said,
I love one who doesn't love me. I love man, man doesn't love me. I give everything to man, he gives
nothing to me. And he goes on like that, I was unlucky in love, says he talks about that as his
failure. So as the union with our will was broken by man, our bitterness began and also his unhappiness,
because all happiness is in the divine will. Therefore the purpose of creation failed.
And it failed because God gave us free will, making us more like him than anything else that he had made.
Now who compensates us for this failure? Who puts in force the proceeds of our creation?
It is the soul who lives in our will. She leaves all generations behind. And as though being the
first to be created by us, she places herself in order according to the purpose for which we
created man. Now, why do we leave all generations behind? And why do we take the first place?
It's because we're the first generation, I say generation now, because we're 100 years after
Louisa. So we're the first generation to decide, yes, I want to live in the divine will, I want to
come back, I want to bring humanity with me, I want to take up where Adam left off. So that's why we
leave all the generations behind, because they did their own will. The soul who lives in my will,
she leaves all generations behind. And as though being the first to be created by us,
she places herself in order according to the purpose for which we created man.
Our will and hers are one. That is the purpose of creation.
And as she operates with the divine will, our will acts in the human will, which is what God wanted.
And here begins our divine proceeds in the human will. This is what God wanted,
that he would be able to work his magnificent project through the human will, and that the whole
of his universe would benefit. The purpose of creation is now in force, once the human will
surrenders to the divine. And since our will has infinite ways, as long as it finds its
a soul who offers herself to let our will act, it immediately recovers from the failure of all
the other human wills. God is the eternal optimist. As soon as he sees any of us make any effort at
all to come back into his will, as far as he's concerned, he's starting all over again.
This is why we love that soul so much, as to surpass all the love for all other creatures
together. Why? Because this soul is doing exactly what God wants.
And this soul is allowing God to do what he wants. This soul is cooperating with God exactly as he
wants. She has rendered the quorum, honor, glory, regime, and life to our will, which is oppressed
and despised in the other creatures. How could we not give everything to her?
Then, as if he couldn't contain his love, he pressed me to his heart and he said everything,
everything to the little daughter of my will. This is a wonderful enthusiasm of love.
I will be in continuous outpouring over you. Your thoughts will be the outpouring of my wisdom.
It's now wonderful. Your thoughts, the outpouring of divine wisdom,
may it happen, Lord, to all of us. Your gazes will be the outpouring of my light,
may God grant that it will happen. Your breath, he said, your heartbeat, your action will be preceded
by my outpourings first and then will have life. May God grant it. And grant that it doesn't just
happen once every now and then, but every single nanosecond of our entire lives so that he receives
the glory, the honor, the praise that he deserves. So be attentive and in everything you do,
think that it is an outpouring of Jesus that comes to you. Now, you need to take that off the page.
You need to write that out on a little note and look at it very frequently. Everything
that you do is an outpouring of Jesus. Wow. Jesus wants to write, Jesus wants to speak,
Jesus wants to give this talk, Jesus wants to communicate with others, Jesus wants to eat,
sleep, whatever, walk. It's fantastic. So December the 28th, 1921, we have fears of
Louisa and Jesus gives her peace. And we have this extraordinary thing where Louisa wants Jesus
to do her will. Now, her will is supposed to have been surrendered to his. And this gives you the
complexity that human beings are. I was feeling very afflicted, she said, with such oppression
that I felt I was dying because of certain things which is not necessary to write about here.
Now, my sweet Jesus on coming took me in his arms in order to sustain me and to give me strength.
Now, that's the song of songs chapter two and verse six. His left hand is under my head and his
right arm embraces me because Louisa actually experiences the whole time that wonderful relationship
that is described in the song of songs. And so he said, my daughter, what is this? You will press
yourself too much. And I don't want that. Now, we're only supposed to do what he wants. And he
says, no, I don't want you to be oppressed. I don't want you to be upset. So Louisa said,
why Jesus helped me do not abandon me to so much bitterness. What oppresses me the most is that I
feel a desire. Now, my book says a volition. It's actually a desire arising in me, which would want
to say to you, this time you do my will and not I yours. That's on the basis that what yours is mine
and what mine is yours. The mere thought of this, she said, gives me death. Oh, how true it is that
your will is life. But the circumstances push me, she said, please help me. And I burst into tears,
she said, Jesus, letting his hands be wet by her tears, squeezed her more, and then began to explain.
Now, this problem that Louisa is illustrating now, and she says it a number of times. I think it reflects
more the situation that we have than that Louisa has. We would be much more inclined to say, well,
if I'm doing his will all the time, it's time for him to do mine. And we mightn't have the depth of
relationship or love that Louisa had when she was saying it, because she was saying that she was
suffering desperately, that this desire was coming up in her. Why would she be suffering?
Because she's totally in the divine will, and the divine will is saying, not this, not this,
not this, the divine will is pushing it out. So he said, my daughter courage, do not fear,
I am all for you. Now, for that, I need to give you Romans eight versus 31 to 38. And it begins with,
if God is on our side, who can be against us. Do you see, he said, how beautiful my hands are,
beaded with the tears of one who fears not doing my will? Not one of them fell to the ground.
Now listen and cam yourself. I will do what you want, but not because you want it, rather,
as if I myself wanted it. So aren't you happy? After all, a little suspension of your state is
necessary. I have no one to whom to entrust you. In other words, the priests really don't understand
what's going on. Who could do it? He said, they have hearts covered with an iron armor. Wow.
Before we get to that, I want to give you a Deuteronomy 32, 15, 12, sorry, that the Lord alone was
her guide. So these priests who are looking after, he says, they're covered with iron armor.
My voices are neither listened to nor understood. The sins are horrendous. The sacrilegious enormous.
Now he's not just talking about the priests around Louisa. He's talking about the church.
The scourges are ready at the doors of the city. There will be great mortality. Therefore,
a little suspension of your state which prevents the course of my justice is actually needed.
You will give me free time to come and I, withdrawing without letting you go out of my will,
will give you all that you need. So, Louisa said she was embittered more than ever because of the
many other things that Jesus told her regarding the sad times. But she hasn't told us. And though
calm, she said, because he assured me that he would not let me go out of his will. But the following day,
our blessed mother came to her and bringing the little baby Jesus to Louisa, she placed him in her
arms and she said, my daughter, hold him tightly. Don't let him go. If you knew what he wants to do,
and she doesn't finish the sentence, pray to him, pray to him, prayer in his will, enraptress him
and chains him. Now, please, all of us, remember that prayer in the divine will,
enraptress him and chains him. It has incredible power. Some of the scourges he said, she said,
would at least be held back. So, having said that she disappeared and Louisa said she returned to
the tragic doubt that she may have induced Jesus to her own will. It's better just to do his and
not think about it. So, here you have whatever was going on. Louisa really wanted Jesus to do
something her way. And then she said, well, you know, you can't really do my will. So,
can we turn it around that somehow is your will? That's also in our complexity. But then our blessed
lady came along and she said, if you only knew what he's going to do in terms of scourges,
you would start praying. So, it's our blessed mother that gets Louisa back into gear.
So, January the 3rd, 1922, the bonds which exist between the divine will and the human will.
So, Jesus said, daughter of my will, come into my will that you may know the relations which are
the connections or the bonds which exist between the divine will and the human will,
which the creature shattered from the very terrestrial Eden. But the soul who knows no other life but
the life of my will rebuilds my will, binds it once again giving back to it all the connections
which the creature has broken and all the bonds of creation and of the principle of existence.
In other words, living in the divine will and doing acts in the divine will, the Lord
allows us to literally rebuild creation.
So, that's called standing in the breach. I'm trying to think of a particular scripture.
Standing in the breach is Sam 106 and I can't remember the verse. And there's another one as
well which slipped my mind just right now. So, the person living and acting in the divine will and
praying in the divine will is allowed, oh yes, to be the breach mender is what I was thinking of
and you'll find that in Isaiah chapter 48. Chapter 48 of Isaiah is a long chapter explaining how
fasting and prayer and responding to the Lord actually rebuilds everything. So, I'll just leave
you the whole chapter. He said these were the bonds of union that had existed between the creator
and the creature. These were relations of likeness, sanctity, knowledge, power. They always use the
word science for some reason or other but we don't use that word in the way it's being used here.
When we talk about science, we're talking about the natural sciences and we're talking about
human beings called scientists. They're not talking about that, they're talking about knowledge
and that's why I always replace the word science with knowledge. So, there were relations of
likeness, sanctity, knowledge and power and Hosea 4-6 tells us that without knowledge,
without this knowledge, the people perish. Look at all the science we have in the world today
and yet society is dying, it's dying spiritually. So, it's not science as we know it. It's true
knowledge which is knowledge of God and knowledge of self and knowledge of real reality and knowledge
of the truth. Jesus says only the truth will set you free. So, everything I contain, he said,
I placed in relationship with man, relations in the order of all created things and to him I gave
primacy over everything. That's Genesis chapter 2 verses 26 to 28 and it's also Sam 8. You've made
him little less than a god. Now, by withdrawing from my will, man broke all of these bonds or
connections between the divine will and the human will and he placed himself in relationship or in
bondage to sin. He placed himself in relationship or bondage to his own passions and with his
fiercest enemy which was the human will. We even say that ourselves, that man is his own
worst enemy or that woman is our own worst enemy. Therefore, the soul who lives in my will rises so
high that is the eagle position spiritually as to leave everyone behind. Now, the opposite of the
eagle are the seagulls squawking on ground level fighting over some little piece of food whereas the
eagle sores into the sky far away from everything and lives so high that they can actually affect
everybody on the earth. The soul who lives high in my will rises so high as to leave everybody
behind. She places herself in order between me and her. Now, we've dealt with that in previous
messages. Placing yourself in order is that you fuse yourself continuously in the divine will
and it's this fusing in the divine will that puts us in order with our creator.
She gives herself back to her origin. That's what we do by fusing in acting in the divine will
and she places all the broken relations in force. So, by reconnecting the divine will with the
human will, we are actually mending the whole thing. All created things form her courtage
and recognize her as their legitimate daughter feeling honored to be dominated by her. That's
the Romans 8, 19 again. The purpose for which they were created, that's the whole creation,
to be commanded and to obey her slightest wishes is already accomplished. Therefore,
all nature remains reverent around her and exalts in seeing that finally its God
receives the glory of the purpose for which he had created it, that observing man. You see,
when the rebellion of man against God happened in the Garden of Eden, all created things were
still in the will of God and so they refused to cooperate with man and that's where the earth
began to refuse to give man the food that he wanted. That's in Genesis chapter 3.
That's where the animals moved away from man and became what we call wild animals.
There was nothing to do with us. They want to fulfill the purpose for which they were created
and they even fight and kill us.
Therefore, all nature remains reverent around her and exalts in seeing that finally its God
receives the glory of the purpose for which he was created, that of serving man. So fire,
light, water, cold, all let themselves be commanded and will faithfully obey
because the divine will is in them and now it's in you. We know by looking at the
lives of St. Francis of Assisi and the other name has just gone out of my head now,
this moment. It will come in a minute that the animals responded to them in the most extraordinary
way and even the story of the wolf of Gobio, it was just simply Francis just talking to the animal.
The animal accepted this beautiful love that was coming from its creator through this man
and submitted it's amazing and Jesus continues
and just as my love immediately prepared the remedy to save man by descending from heaven
and becoming incarnate. So this soul who lives in my will by giving herself back to the beginning
to her eternal origin from which she came, that is the pre-fall state, even before my humanity
was formed already kissed and adored my blood and my wounds, honored my steps and my works
and formed a worthy courtage of my humanity, even before we came into existence. Isn't that
unbelievable? So I want to give you Philippians 2 verses 6 to 11, the descent of the second person
of the blessed Trinity to become man. "O soul who lives in my will," Jesus said, "you alone are the
purpose of the glory of creation. You are the decorum and the honor of my works.
You are the fulfillment of my redemption." Now that praise coming from the Redeemer is unbelievable.
It's incredible. In you I centralized everything. You remember he had centralized all of redemption
in his blessed mother so that everything would be safe in her and then in Louisa he centralizes
everything in the divine will so that everything would be safe in her. In you I centralized everything.
May all relations and connections and bonds between God and the creation be given back to you.
And if out of weakness you should fail, for the decorum and the honor of my will
will make up for you in everything. So Jesus says that even if Louisa should fail, his divine will
would make up for everything because after all she was born like the rest of us in original sin.
She has a weakness that blessed mother never knew about because she was perfect and whole
right from the very beginning and the divine will was whole and complete in her from the
very beginning. Therefore he said be attentive and give this highest contentment to your Jesus.
So we go on to January the 5th 1922. The divine being is led by an irresistible force
to communicate itself to the creature because divine love communicates. It's simple.
So Louisa said I was feeling very embittered in my sweet Jesus on coming,
gasping me all to himself told me. My daughter your reflection weighs upon my heart more than if it
was my own because they are inseparable in the divine will. I cannot bear that you be so
embittered and I want to see you happy at any cost. I want to see the smile that the
beatitude of my will brings. That's Philippians 4-4. God wants you to be happy.
I want to see that smile arise on your lips again. Tell me then what do you want so that I may render
you happy again. Is it possible that after so much time in which you denied me nothing
I should not give you what you want to make you content. So again I remind you of the testimony
of Padre Pio that when he was asked why was it that the Lord had worked such wonders and signs
through him he said simply I deny him nothing and he denies me nothing. It's that simple.
Love lives by giving, by giving everything. So Louisa said my love what I want is that you will
give me your grace to always always do your will and that is something that we need to ask the Lord
on a daily basis as well that he would give us the grace to always do his will. He said that's enough
for me how much I fear that I may not do it he said isn't this the greatest misfortune not doing
your will even in the smallest thing. Now why would a woman sitting in a bed not going anywhere
have this problem it's much more understandable for you and me we're living in the world we have
all the distractions of family life and work and all the rest of it it's much more understandable
that we would have the problem where is she getting the problem. She's obviously getting it from the
priests who are arguing about this and that and the other that's being said to her about by Jesus
by things that they're saying she should or should not do. We know she had a lot of visitors
so there was influence coming in through other people and very often our difficulties come
through our reactions with other people as well. So she said how much I fear that I wouldn't do your
will isn't this the greatest misfortune not doing your will even in the smallest thing.
Yet your proposals your very attentions induce me to this because I see that you want to do my will
not because this is your will but because you want to make me happy and empty my heart of the bitterness
at which it is soaked. As she said Jesus don't do this so he finds her completely embittered
wants to do whatever it is she wants to make her happy and then she realizes oh no no this is not
the way it should be. I should be doing his will and whatever makes him happy. She said don't permit
this if you want to make me happy your power does not lack other means to take me away from my
affliction. And then Jesus said my daughter my daughter daughter of my will no don't fear God
always says to us do not fear fear is Satan's weapon. I will never it will never be that our
wills will even be injured. You see they have become one they are inseparable and he's trying
to get her to understand that inseparable means that her will is his and his will is hers.
If a miracle is necessary Jesus said I will do it but our wills will never separate would not be
unbelievably wonderful if he could say that about you and me. Therefore come yourself he said on
this regard and be cheered. Listen my being is led by an irresistible force to communicate itself
to the creature. Now we've already had this in December the 23rd 1921. I have yet many more
things to tell you many more truths of which you don't know. All of my truths carry the happiness
that each one of them contains. And as many truths as the soul knows so many different types
of happiness she acquires. So he's saying that happiness is not just blanking out whatever is
upsetting you as if it never existed. He doesn't do that kind of thing. There's no abricadabra.
There's no magic. He said happiness is not like that. Your happiness is going to be in the realization
that every single new truth that is given to you carries with it its own load of happiness. And when
we collect all these truths we will have discovered what true happiness on the earth really is.
Now in finding your heart in bitter they feel that their happiness is being shaded and they cannot
communicate themselves freely. If you remember that even at the very beginning of his ministry
Jesus gave us seven happinesses. Seven be attitudes. And you'll find them in Matthew 5 verses 1 to 12.
And he was saying if you have this attitude if you live like this you will be happy.
But how many people live the way the Beatitudes describe. Jesus said I'm like a happy father who
possesses the fullness of the whole of happiness and wants to make all of his children happy.
That's Philippians 4 or 4 again. Now if he sees that one of his children really loves him
as distinct from all the others who say they do. And he sees that one melancholy and pensive.
At any cost he wants to make his child happy and to free him from that embarrassment.
All the saints have told us that God doesn't like Sarah or saints.
He actually wants us to be happy on the earth. He can make us happy eternally but he wants us
to be happy on the earth as well. And if the father knows that that melancholy or sadness
is caused by the love the child has for him. Oh he then can give himself no peace. He uses all
of his arts and makes any sacrifice to render his child happy. He said that's what I'm like.
And since I know that your affliction is because of me he said if I do not see you come back again
to your state of joy and be marked by my own happiness I'll make myself unhappy waiting for you
to return into the arms of my happiness. So Louisa had allowed that melancholy which has been described
quite a number of times to invade her so that she wasn't outwardly experiencing this happiness
and she wasn't outwardly, I didn't say experiencing, portraying this happiness to others. And that
would be a big thing for him because the only way that these priests and the people visiting her
would know that something marvelous was happening in her was to see this peaceful happy aspect.
So January the 11th 1922 the souls who live in the divine will will be for the body of the
church like skin holding the body together. Isn't that amazing? So I want to give you one
Corinthians 12, 1230 which describes the church as a body of believers and there are different
parts of the body have different functions so now you know that the divine will people,
the divine will family are the skin holding the whole church together. Isn't that amazing?
Finding myself in my usual state Louisa said I was thinking about the holy divine will and I said
to myself, all the children of the church are members of the mystical body of which Jesus is
the head. What place will the souls who do the will of God occupy in the mystical body of Christ?
That's actually a very important question because when you read the testimony of St. Therese of
Lysu at a certain point in her life she said, "Now I have found my place in the church. I am in the
heart of the church. I am love. I'm in the heart of the church." So the divine will family are the
skin holding the whole church together. We don't let it fall apart. We keep everything in place.
My daughter, the church is my mystical body of which I glory and being the head
but in order to enter this mystical body the members must grow to a proper stature
otherwise they would deform the body. But alas, how many not only do not have the true proportion,
they're rotten. They're wounded. So much is to be disgusting to my head and to the other healthy
members. So I want to give you their Habakkuk 113. Lord, your eyes are too holy to look upon sin.
That's Habakkuk, H-A-B-B 113. Your eyes are too holy to look upon sin.
Now the souls who live or will live looking at the future in my will will be for the body of the
church like skin to the body. The body has internal skin and external skin and because in the skin
there is the blood circulation which gives life to the whole body it is by virtue of this circulation
that the members reach the proper stature. Now if we were only the skin on the outside
we were just holding the thing together. But if you are the internal skin there is a very delicate
membrane covering all the internal organs of our bodies and if that very delicate membrane
becomes ill you die. That very delicate membrane is essential for the health of the body and he says
that the souls living in the divine will form the internal skin as well as the external skin
of the body and therefore enables the whole church to reach its maturity. If it wasn't for the skin
and for the blood circulation the human body would be horrid to the side and its members would never
grow to due proportion. See how these souls who live in my will are necessary to me and now you see
it because our bodies would literally fall apart without that internal skin and without the external
skin. Since I have destined them to be like skin to the body of the church and the circulation of
life to all the members now you know that in the blood circulation all food and all life is given
to every cell of the body. Therefore the people who are living in the divine will and operating in
the divine will are giving life to the whole church to every part of it. They will be the ones who
will give the proper growth to the members who have not grown and who will heal the wounded members
now we're not talking about physical healing we're skin okay so the healing therefore is
reparation and substitution for everything that's wrong and who will restore the freshness the beauty
and the splendor of the whole mystical body by their continuous living in my will. It's really
wonderful so we have a task to do for every member of the church just as we have a task
for every soul that lives past, present and future but it's lovely to know where you actually fit in
the church because if you know where you fit you will know how to be enthusiastic for the mission
that was given to you. So the souls living in the divine will are all are to heal the wounded
members restore the freshness to the church and the beauty and the splendor of the whole mystical
body by their continuous living in my will rendering the body of Christ fully similar to the head I
think that's magnificent you see if you examine a human body every cell has an essential part in
it your soul is in every part of your body people don't realize that they somehow think the soul is
in the head it's in every part of your body so that's why if they cut off part of the arm the body
feels the pain of the bit that's being cut off because the soul that had been in that part of
the arm has had to retreat up to the top of the arm it's still there and it remembers there's memory
in every part of your body there's intelligence in every part of your body and so it's the most
wonderful thing here that the the people living in the divine will will restore every part of the
body so that it is similar to the head literally healing the church I think this is wonderful
and so there's no need for us to get involved in any criticism or
any chatter about what's wrong in the church we just get on with healing it it's wonderful
so they render the body fully similar to the head which is Jesus
and this head will sit in full majesty upon these members why because these members have the divine
will in them as he has this is why the end of days cannot come if I do not have these souls
who live as though dissolved in my will now there's a great talk nowadays about the end of the world
we're in the end of an era and the beginning of a new era but they seem to think it's the end
of the world as in end end end and Jesus says if he doesn't get souls living in the divine will
nothing's gonna end because his will will be done on earth as it is and ever that's it
and so the more of us who become involved in cooperating with him in the rebuilding of the church
the better and so he said these souls interest me more than anything because it allows him to do
what he wants and that's the rebuilding of the church and therefore the rebuilding of humanity
and therefore the reconstruction of all of creation or the reordering I suppose will be the correct
word of all of creation what impression would this mystical body make in the celestial Jerusalem
without them and if this is what interests me more than anything it must interest you also more than
anything else because we're in the era of the fulfillment of the our father die will be done on
earth in the same way as it's done in heaven and if this is what interest me more than anything else
it must interest you more than anything else as well if you love me from now on I will give to your
acts done in my will the power of circulation of life in the whole mystical body of the church
there is divine goodness divine goodness he's the only one who can give that though that power
to our acts we can only make the act he has to do everything else that's why he says you desire
it and I'll actually do it but he he needs us to participate we have to put our drop of water
into the wine of his redemption we have to put our drop of water into the wine of his love
just like the blood circulation in the human body your acts extended within the
immensity of my will will extend over everyone and will cover these members of the church
like skin giving them proper growth therefore he said be attentive and be faithful it's such a
wonderful mission it's fantastic so louisa said afterwards she was praying all abandoned in the
will of Jesus and almost without thinking she said my love everything in your will my little pains
my prayers my heartbeat my breathing all that I am and all that I can united to all that you are
as to give proper growth to the members of the body of the church oh wow there's the prayer
it's absolutely fantastic and of course she's being pushed by Jesus to do that because the divine
will is operating within her so there it is we fuse ourselves in the divine will and we say
Lord I want to put all my little pains all my prayers all my heartbeats all my breathing
all that I am and all that I can do if I can do anything united to you and all that you are
so as to give proper growth to the members of the mystical body of Christ it's wonderful
in hearing me Jesus made himself seen again and smiling with satisfaction he added
how beautiful it is to see my truths in your heart as a fount of life immediately having the
development and the effect for which they have communicated themselves in other words it's I'm
thrilled that you have understood what I said and you've put it into practice there's your letter
of James again James chapter one from verse 22 to 26 it is extremely important for us to hear the
word of God and put it into practice otherwise it's wasted on us how beautiful he said to see my
truths in your heart as a fount of life immediately having the development and the effect for which
they have communicated themselves therefore respond and as soon as I see one truth developed in you
I will make it an honor for myself to make another fount of truth arise in you of course if we don't
respond there is no obligation on him to give us something else he's not going to throw his
pearls before swine does that mean we're swine no it means that swine are not interested in pearls
they're only interested in the the the food that makes them fat every day they're not interested
in anything else so the interest of the swine is absolutely at the lowest level it's just me
and survival so if that's where we're at no way would he give his treasures to us but if we take
his treasures as jewels and gems and we immediately put them into practice oh yes he'll give us more
and more and more I want to stop there